Ronnie put this radio in there you know
that has Sirius XM but it's not made by
Sirius XM it's made by another company
and it's waterproof I think it's made
mostly for boats so we get this radio in
there
and I'm in there with my wife and I go
jeez this [ __ ] radio keeps flashing
up commercials she was what do you mean
and we look at it the screen keeps
changing so I I go I'll turn it off it
won't turn off you got to keep pressing
this piece of rubber really hard finally
I get it to turn off
Robyn I swear to God as God is my
witness two seconds later the like in
the twilight zone the radio turned
itself back on he comes back on [ __ ]
car I go what the hell that's impossible
then I get it again I turn it off it
comes back on keeps coming back on like
it's haunting me his [ __ ] radio is
chasing me like I I was gonna jump out
the window which would have been great
radio gave me my life and also tilled me
where I go what happened to a normal
radio you have a switch you turn it on
you turn off why do I have a boat radio
in a car
I got a [ __ ] boat radio I just want a
radio I can turn on and off I would say
the name of the company but you know
them out there is out there talking
under here yelling out there I can't
even look out the window in this car I'm
gonna get started with that yes when
you're designing the car you could have
left space for a bigger radio no because
then you can't put it in that spot well
then put it in a different space and
then you'll tell me you can't reach it
I've never heard of a remote yeah but
she got a good point dude you couldn't
get the radio turned off either
you got it turned off we couldn't turn
it back on he goes to me I got a
solution don't turn it off I don't
always run on you know what I had to do
to work the radio one day I had to call
the Coast Guard cuz okay and they came
and turned it off for me the radios in
the bow yeah Ronnie we ever drive off a
bridge the radio what do I want I wanna
be able to turn the radio on I said the
same thing they don't make [ __ ] [ __ ]
will you just turn the switch and the
radio comes on
everything's with computerized and and
brains it's got a separate brain wish
you had a separate brain I came
downstairs this man Ronny was swabbing
the deck hoist the mainsail would take
it off for serious I think I got
barnacles on my steering wheel put him
in a big sail or out
we couldn't get the radio working goes
you know just radio it's made for boats
that's how I said it the other day
Ronnie and I sustained some giant waves
and I got news via my radio didn't break
[Music]
[Laughter]
way to take my theme song coming on
iceberg ahead don't worry the radio the
crow's nest put a big frozenness Robin
yeah my car is sinking there's only room
for one of us you're gonna have to go
hang on outside oh the light turn red
Ronnie drop anchor hold on I got to
adjust my eye patch are you wearing your
eyes
[Laughter]